[Musique]
bonsoir et elle brune Pivet bonsoir et
merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté
l'invitation de la Chaîne Parlementaire
une heure pour vous interroger en direct
sur cette nouvelle assemblée qui fait
beaucoup de bruit ces derniers jours
allure de chaudron parfois mais qui est
capable quand même d'avancer malgré
l'absence de majorité absolue avec Elsa
bonsoir à voisin on va revenir sur
l'actualité parlementaire sur votre
manière de présider au perchoir et puis
sur les réformes importantes à venir je
le disais les retraites ça y est on
entre dans le dur et puis dans la
deuxième partie et bien vous serez
interrogé par deux de nos affranchis de
chroniqueurs de visages familiers de
l'émission Pierre-Henri tavoyau sur la
crise de la démocratie c'est un
philosophe et puis une féministe
également et une journaliste que vous
connaissez je crois les haches en
Boncelles qui a décidé de revenir avec
vous sur la grande cause du quinquennat
du quinquennat premier et du deuxième
quinquennat à l'égalité homme-femme mais
on commence par votre portrait signé
Tchaikovski bonsoir Stéphane bonsoir
Elsa bonsoir madame la presse
l'histoire d'une ascension
[Musique]
de l'Assemblée nationale jusqu'au là je
me trompe pas pour nous c'est notre star
mais les Français je pense ne la
connaissent pas encore très bien
regardez les sondages du mois de
novembre il y a un baromètre sauce donc
c'est pas tout à fait son âge voyez il y
a 12% d'avis favorable 31 défavorable
mais il y a surtout 57% des Français qui
ne se prononcent pas tout simplement
parce que je pense qu'ils ne savent pas
exactement qui vous êtes ou pas encore
bien qui vous êtes vraiment vous pensez
que les Français ne la connaissent pas
vous êtes en train en politique il y a
seulement cinq ans donc forcément à
l'époque où vous souvenez des titres des
articles la seule question qui barrait
tous les articles vous concernant
c'était mais qui est Yaël on se
demandait forcément alors je les ai lu
ces articles il y a évidemment on
rapporte le début de notre parcours vous
êtes né à Nancy vous avez été avocat de
pénaliste que vous avez 50 enfants vous
avez vécu 7 ans à l'étranger parce que
votre mari est expatrié donc c'était
Taïwan enfin Japon et donc Portugal vous
êtes rentrés en France vous êtes occupé
de centre de dans les Yvelines des
Restos du cœur et donc là on peut dire
que jusque là à part peut-être votre
poste de trésorier de la section locale
du PS à Tokyo d'ailleurs c'est que vous
avez pas vraiment fait de politique vous
n'êtes pas du côté Darmanin Attal tomber
dedans quand ils étaient petits on s'en
passe à chez vous alors une fois élu en
revanche le parcours est plutôt
exemplaire à l'Assemblée exemplaire
dites exceptionnel franchement
2017 à Ténérife vous êtes présidente de
la commission des lois 2018 l'année
suivante vous vous présentez à la
Présidence de l'Assemblée nationale bah
pourquoi pas bon Richard Ferrand qui
joue du Président vous bat cette fois-ci
mais encore mieux regardez 2021 vous
êtes quoi député de l'année donc il y a
quand même un très beau parcours et
pourtant lorsque vous rentrez au
gouvernement juin dernier on se dit
c'est mérité après tout ce parcours
maintenant les journalistes qu'est-ce
qu'ils veulent savoir ils savent
toujours pas mais
la nouvelle ministre de l'Outre-mer
parce que ça ne rentre pas dans la tête
des gens et puis le pire c'est que après
vous démissionnez du gouvernement donc
un mois plus tard
vous êtes élu président de l'Assemblée
qu'est-ce qu'ils veulent savoir les
journalistes
nous alors on va peut-être répondre à la
question maintenant Stéphane
très bien à mon sens le combat que même
aujourd'hui beaucoup de femmes pour
avoir plus de responsabilités en
politique si je reprends quelques
éléments de votre parcours en 2017 vous
êtes candidats dont on les Yvelines
personne vous connaît votre anniversaire
c'est Jacques Millard un pilier de
l'Assemblée quatre mandats qui avaient
été élu l'année précédente le macho de
l'année bon vous en avez qu'une bouchée
mais des machos il y en a d'autres il a
toujours sur votre chemin quand vous
êtes exigeant de présidente de la
commission des lois qu'est-ce qui se
passe il y a deux candidats face à vous
plus expérimentés des vieux mâles blancs
et voilà vous gagnez résultat ce qui se
passe c'est que il y en a un qui est
tellement vexé qui ne veut pas se piéger
dans la commission parce que c'est une
femme qui a été élue encore cette année
quand vous avez été du président de
l'Assemblée il y avait un rivale
masculin contre vous c'était Roland
Lescure qui est un peu le chouchou de
l'Élysée du Boys Club de l'Elysée encore
des garçons il toujours des hommes qui
se mettent un peu en travers de vos
chemins ça vous empêche pas d'avancer
apparemment et donc du coup je me suis
demandé si la phrase que vous avez
prononcée quand vous avez pris la prison
de l'Assemblée c'était pas une phrase
qui vous concernait un peu on réécoute
cette phrase
mes chers collègues
le chemin de l'égalité entre les hommes
et les femmes oui c'était long parce que
peut-être vous avez mis longtemps vont
commencer puis après sinon parce qu'il
faut quand même éviter tous ces tous ces
adversaires donc alors jusqu'où il peut
mener ce sinuer et long chemin si
j'étais capable de produire l'avenir
pensez bien que je vous demanderai un
peu plus cher pour mes chroniques
certainement ou peut-être tout
simplement que je suis en train de faire
des paris sur la Coupe du monde donc non
tout ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
moi il me semble que il y a deux choses
sur lesquelles on va sans doute vous
juger c'est premièrement votre capacité
à défendre le rôle de l'Assemblée
nationale bah là on a un exemple comme
la foi ou vous avez fait savoir vous
étiez opposé à ce que la réforme des
retraites passe par un amendement alors
que Lisée il réfléchissait pas mal
d'ailleurs j'ai cru comprendre que
c'était un peu tendu avec les lysas à
cet endroit là en tout cas c'est ce que
dit l'opinion qui est bien renseignée la
présidente qui échappe à Macron
glacial avec vous puis l'autre point sur
lequel évidemment on va forcément bouger
c'est la bonne tenue des débats à
l'Assemblée et on comprend bien que
c'est pas facile avec cette nouvelle
Assemblée il y a une image qui a frappé
tout le monde c'est lorsque les racistes
ont été tenus tout le monde est descendu
des gradins il a fallu rétablir l'ordre
bon c'était peut-être pas facile au
départ mais finalement vous avez pris
une sanction exemplaire contre Grégoire
de Fornas en l'excluant pendant 15 jours
ce qui n'était quasiment jamais arrivé
une seule fois et vous avez fait donc
une nouvelle déclaration d'intention à
l'issue de cet incendie de cette
incidence au débat démocratique ne
serait tout permettre
tellement pas l'invective l'insulte
certainement pas le racisme j'en appelle
à la dignité de nos débats au refus de
toute haine et de toute violence
fut-elle verbale et au respect de nos
valeurs de nos concitoyens et de notre
Assemblée nationale et j'y veillerai à
chaque instant
donc forcément moi je me pose une
question je me demande est-ce que là
vous avez le sentiment d'avoir réussi à
installer votre autorité donc le plus
dur est fait ou face à ce chaudron
bouillant qui est devenu l'assemblée
vous diriez plutôt l'inverse que le plus
dur reste à venir réponse
compliquée parce que
l'Assemblée nationale n'est pas ce
chaudron que parfois certains décrivent
et ouais on voit des moments très agités
mais vous qui êtes des spécialistes de
l'Assemblée nationale vous savez que ça
n'est pas le quotidien de notre
assemblée moi j'ai la conviction que
notre assemblée peut il va fonctionner
pour servir nos compatriotes et moi je
pense avoir installé mais d'autres le
diront probablement à ma place la
présidence qui doit être la mienne avec
la fermeté nécessaire pour pouvoir
permettre à l'assemblée de fonctionner
mais la bienveillance également voilà
une espèce de de moi je pense de
fait de ce que doit ouais c'est de ce
que doit être notre assemblée ça c'est
du côté de la présidence respecter
l'institution respecter les oppositions
mais quand on voit les députés les
images
tout à fait bien sûr c'est eux qui vous
Élise mais il y a quand même un peu un
des faits terrible en terme d'image
quand on va les retrouver toutes ces
images notamment celles de jeudi soir
sur la réintégration des des soignants
non vaccinés c'est facile à présider une
telle assemblée franchement on vous a vu
parfois un peu hésité sur les sanctions
à prendre sur les levées de séances
c'est difficile non non c'est difficile
et certains me disent que c'est
peut-être l'Assemblée nationale la plus
difficile à présider de l'histoire de la
5ème république donc ça non ça n'est pas
facile c'est complexe c'est complexe
parce que il n'y a pas de majorité
absolue et c'est complexe parce qu'il y
a 10 groupes politiques qui représentent
l'ensemble du spectre politique qui
existe
euh en France aujourd'hui et donc c'est
nécessairement complexe mais je trouve
que c'est passionnant et avec en
agissant en étant à l'écoute en étant le
chantre du dialogue
j'y arrive et j'ai installé des très
bonnes relations avec l'ensemble des
présidents de groupe avec l'ensemble des
parlementaires qui me permettent jusqu'à
depuis 5 mois de faire fonctionner cette
assemblée et je crois que c'est notre
intérêt commun alors on va venir sur les
textes qui sont à l'agenda mais il y a
aussi des textes qui sont qui ont été
adoptés avec des compromis mais tout de
même permettez-moi d'insister vous dites
c'est bien d'une certaine façon cette
assemblée elle représente qu'on
souhaitait les Français pas sûr qu'il
s'y retrouve quand même dans certains
débats on va retrouver quelques images
grâce à Stéphanie Despierre morceau
choisi sur cette proposition de loi
insoumise c'était jeudi soir dans la
nuit sur la question de réintégrer non
les soignants non vaccinés regardez
[Applaudissements]
s'il
vous plaît vous êtes contents d'avoir pu
trouver une petite mesquinerie obscive
pour ne pas laisser une niche aller
jusqu'au bout
tu vas la faire fermer
[Applaudissements]
non monsieur serveur c'est une invictive
monsieur Servane
chers collègues on peut pas en venir aux
affectives de cette manière là la séance
est suspendue pour 5 minutes pas
possible alors je vous rappelle les
règles
pardon pardon monsieur Bernal ici
qu'est-ce que vous avez à dire
bien sûr on n'est pas à Versailles ça
c'est sûr on est vraiment au cirque
aujourd'hui bon
[Applaudissements]
j'y étais donc pendant la recherche de
la planète mes chers s'il vous plaît
ceux qui veulent
mais un peu de respect pour ceux qui
restent un peu de respect pour ceux qui
restent bon maintenant vous sortez
alors vous n'étiez pas au perchoir on le
voit ce soir là c'est à la hauteur tout
de même ce spectacle ou pas
non non il est vrai que les concitoyens
nos concitoyens nous en parlent et nous
disent que ce qui se passe parfois dans
l'hémicycle n'est pas à la hauteur n'est
pas à l'auteur de nos responsabilités du
mandat que nous devons exercer et ils
sont assez effrayés de l'incapacité
parfois qui est l'anneau à discuter à
dialoguer à des battre de façon
respectueuse et parfaitement
démocratique donc c'est pour ça que
régulièrement j'en appelle au calme
régulièrement j'en appelle au respect et
c'est régulièrement elles sont pas
forcément toujours entendu mais à faut
vraiment si on devait faire des
statistiques c'est peut-être aller 10%
de nos séances 5% de nos séances qui se
déroulent de la sorte moi je préside
beaucoup parce que j'aime l'hémicycle
j'aime le débat donc je suis beaucoup en
séance et la majorité de l'océans ne se
déroule pas comme cela tu vois
d'ailleurs pas le quotidien de
l'Assemblée c'est très important très
régulièrement mais tout de même Elsa
revenons à un instant sur cette ambiance
surchauffée elle pose la question de
l'obstruction parlementaire oui puisque
pour rappeler le contexte c'était la
semaine dernière jeudi c'était la
journée d'initiative parlementaire de la
France insoumise c'est à dire qu'ils
peuvent présenter plusieurs textes alors
il faut adopter le droit à l'avortement
dans la Constitution finalement il
retire le texte sur la corrida et les
députés un peu surpris se retrouvent à
discuter d'un texte qui était pas
vraiment prévu au programme la
réintégration des soignants non vaccinés
c'est un texte qui sur le fond et un peu
épidermique très clivant donc déjà ça
nourrit de nombreux débats mais la
majorité va vite se rendre compte qu'en
fait elle peut perdre sur ce texte parce
que les oppositions sont plutôt toute
favorable et là elle va décider bien le
gouvernement va déposer un amendement ce
qui va permettre aux députés du groupe
renaissance de déposer des dizaines des
centaines de sous amendements derrière
et finalement de faire une obstruction
assumer par la majorité et c'est aussi
cela que reprochait les oppositions
alors question sur l'autrection elle
émane du gouvernement en l'occurrence
reprise par des amendements sous
amendements de la majorité est-ce que
toutes les obstructions d'où qu'elles
viennent sont déplorables d'une façon
générale l'obstruction est là pour
éviter le débat et donc moi en tant que
président de l'Assemblée nationale je ne
peux que la déplorer d'où qu'elle vienne
après compris
là ce qui s'est passé c'est une mauvaise
gestion de la niche parlementaire je
rappelle et on nous en avons discuté
avec les présidents de groupe nous en
avions d'ores et déjà discuté en amont
en conférence des présidents il n'est
pas possible d'inscrire 12 textes comme
l'avait fait la France insoumise à
perdre du jour d'une niche parlementaire
vous savez c'est 12 textes c'est du
travail pour les fonctionnaires de
l'Assemblée parce que moi j'ai toujours
considéré et c'est bien normal que les
textes qui sont présentés dans une niche
doivent être aussi bien travaillées que
n'importe quel autre texte en
l'occurrence ce texte aurait pu être
adopté en amont c'est du travail
exactement qui sont préparés par les
parlementaires par le gouvernement sauf
que les oppositions elles disent on a
une journée une petite journée par
session et bien on doit la gérer de
façon il faut déposer des textes mais
moi j'ai évoqué l'idée de limiter le
nombre de textes à 8 vous voyez bien que
c'est pas une idée de brider les
oppositions mais il faut être
raisonnable parce que vous savez vous
donner aussi de l'espoir à certains nos
concitoyens vous mettez des débats sur
la page publique en leur disant nous
allons porter tel texte et puis
finalement le texte n'est pas porté
je pense qu'il faut qu'il soit en
l'occurrence parce que nous aurions pu
discuter des textes les uns après les
autres je pense qu'il faut qu'on trouve
un bon mode de fonctionnement nous avons
beaucoup de choses à inventer c'est ce
que je souhaite conduire avec l'ensemble
des présidents de groupe nous y avons
tous intérêt sérieusement quand vous
voyez ces images on est tous perdants et
au final c'est la démocratie qui va pas
s'attarder uniquement sur ce type
d'images mais tout de même il y a un
autre élément qui peut peut-être
expliquer toutes ces infectifs les
réseaux sociaux il y a énormément de
vidéos de députés qui sont parfois
découpées par les élus eux-mêmes qui
sont reprises sur Twitter ou sur Tik Tok
les réseaux sociaux tout est filmé on le
sait dans l'hémicycle alliés ou ennemis
du Parlement heureusement que tout est
filmé parce que c'est une nous sommes
dans une démocratie et nous ne
délibérons pas en cachette ou en
catimini il faut que ça se fasse aux
yeux des Français après il est interdit
normalement de diffuser lorsque l'on est
en hémicycle et nous discuterons au
prochain Bureau de du cas de certains
députés qui font des twitchs on dirait
en direct et nous pourrons évoquer cela
en bureaux moi je considère que cela ne
doit pas exister donc il faut faire
attention maintenant les réseaux sociaux
nous permettent aussi de toucher nos
concitoyens et donc il faut en faire un
bon usage plus jeune notamment et
réseaux sociaux ça leur permet de faire
sortir un petit peu ces débats de
l'Assemblée vers les plus jeunes qui
vont pouvoir alors effectivement pas
regarder l'entièreté des débats mais au
moins essayer peut-être de comprendre
voir les positions des uns et des autres
oui je pense que c'est important de
pouvoir toucher tous les publics la
démocratie elle nous appartient
l'Assemblée nationale c'est notre bien
commun et donc si grâce aux médias à
vous aux réseaux sociaux nous arrivons à
toucher le plus grand nombre c'est une
bonne chose maintenant il faut faire
attention il ne faut pas les dévoyer et
il ne faut surtout pas que nous les
utilisions les uns contre les autres on
peut suivre les débats sur le compte
Twitter de notre chaîne un tout petit
mot quand même parce que là c'est une
insulte et c'est carrément de la
grossièreté tu vas la fermer on entend
ça sur le plateau de Cyril Hanouna il y
a une anonymisation du débat
parlementaire les députés de tout bord
défilent sur ce plateau là vous non
pourquoi d'ailleurs moi parce que il ne
m'a jamais invité tout bêtement je pense
que oui pourquoi pas tout dépend pour
parler de quoi avec qui comment parce
que moi je pense que les politiques
doivent aller partout mais que nous
devons partout respecter la fonction qui
est la nôtre vous savez quand vous
faites de la politique vous ne vous
appartenez plus vous exercez un mandat
exercer un mandat c'est exercer une
mission pour quelqu'un d'autre et nous
exerçons cette mission pour les Français
et donc nous devons à travers notre
attitude à travers notre langage nos
habits notre façon nos postures être
digne de ce mandat que nous exerçons et
donc moi je pense que nous nous n'avons
rien à gagner à dévoyé cette fonction
parlementaire alors on va parler des
compromis
possible je rappelle que le septième
49.3 était déclenché par la première
ministre pour adopter définitivement le
budget de la Sécurité sociale c'était
cet après-midi dans l'hémicycles mais
restons un instant sur vous il y a le
Braun Pivet elle va vous être allé voir
les députés pour leur demander un peu ce
qu'il pensait de la présidente à la fois
face et hors caméra exactement j'ai mené
ma grande enquête salée quatre colonnes
bon c'est j'ai trouvé beaucoup de
députés effectivement je leur ai donné
le je leur ai demandé leur avis sur leur
présidente ce qui est assez marquant
c'est que les députés des oppositions
globalement ils sont assez bienveillants
je crois que c'est un terme que vous
appréciez alors ils sont pas
dithyrambique ni complètement élogieux
je vais pas exagérer mais c'est vrai
qu'ils ont une bonne appréciation de
vous et il loue surtout votre qualité de
dialogue et d'écouter
beaucoup d'écoute
et la volonté de faire évoluer le
travail d'un autre institution
l'assemblée travaille bien avec Madame
ronprivee les séances sont bien tenues
avec elles tout le monde peut s'exprimer
donc je pense que c'est une présidente
et la première d'ailleurs président de
l'Assemblée nationale très républicaine
c'est une présidente qui est dans une
situation compliquée et c'est plutôt
d'être apaisante et de maintenir une
forme de de concorde entre les
parlementaires honnêtement c'est pas
évident et puis je n'oublie pas que la
présidente de l'Assemblée n'était pas la
candidate d'Emmanuel Macron ce qui je
laisse un peu de sympathie pour elle une
certaine détermination et
ne pas se méprendre sur ses ambitions et
sur ses capacités
alors là où ça se corse un peu il y a le
brune Pivet c'est souvent le cas en
politique c'est dans votre propre camp
j'ai pas dû insister beaucoup pour
recueillir quelques remarques un peu
acide sur vous alors bien évidemment en
off c'est à dire hors micro et hors
caméra il y a trois angles d'attaque
qu'on retrouve souvent regardé ce que
certains disent de vous elle surtraite
les oppositions façon de dire que vous
êtes bah même un peu plus indulgente
avec les autres qu'avec les vôtres il y
a une autre critique elle ne joue pas
assez collectif on vous reproche parfois
en forme une forme de manque de
solidarité avec parfois l'action
gouvernementale et puis ça parle
beaucoup aussi sur votre ambition elle a
le droit d'avoir de l'ambition mais là
c'est trop et c'est trop tôt alors
évidemment pour vos soutiens et vous en
avez dans la majorité on le rappelle ils
vous ont élu à votre place si on vous
critique c'est bien pour vous c'est
parce que vous comptez regardez
elle a ce devoir à la fois d'être
transpartisanes et de représenter
l'équilibre de l'ensemble des
représentants des groupes et elle est
aussi membre de notre groupe donc c'est
une dualité qu'elle doit exercer je
pense qu'elle le fait avec beaucoup de
d'éthique et que peut-être parfois ça
peut un peu heurter certains mais c'est
son rôle c'est son rôle de président de
l'Assemblée nationale les gens audacieux
sont souvent critiqués et les gens qui
qui veulent faire bouger les choses sont
soumises à la critique c'est logique
voilà c'est logique mais en tout cas
elle a du courage elle a de l'audace et
elle a une détermination qui est
nécessaire pour bien
piloter cette boutique
bon c'est plutôt équilibré mais c'est
quand même intéressant de voir que dans
l'opposition là c'est que des louanges
vous avez quand même un côté un peu
front tireuse vous l'assumez vous avez
pris parfois quelques quelques biais
vous avez marqué une différence avec
votre propre cinq ans Stéphane Blacko
Skil rappelait sur sur les retraites ça
vous assumait je l'assume complètement
parce que à chaque fois il s'agit de
porter des convictions qui me sont
chères et en politique je pense qu'il ne
faut pas mentir il ne faut pas se mentir
et quand vous vous engagez en politique
c'est parce que vous avez des valeurs
parce que vous avez des convictions
parce que l'ambition
c'est pas un gros mot maintenant
l'ambition qui est la mienne aujourd'hui
elle se porte uniquement pour
l'Assemblée nationale parce que cette
institution doit retrouver pleinement sa
place dans notre République dans le cœur
de nos concitoyens dans notre vie
démocratique et c'est ça mon ambition
j'ai donc vous êtes là pour 5 ans au
perchoir c'est ça cinq ans au perchoir
et
chaque seconde que je passe au perchoir
et consacré à cette institution que
j'aime profondément j'ai j'ai quitté le
gouvernement et j'ai pris le risque de
le gouvernement pour revenir à
l'Assemblée nationale dans un contexte
très difficile je n'étais pas assurée
d'être élu mais je l'ai fait parce que
j'aime profondément l'institution et
j'aime profondément
cette ce lieu où des gens qui ne sont
pas d'accord entre eux alors qui n'ont
pas les mêmes convictions doivent
travailler ensemble pour construire et
la question c'est comment c'est la
méthode du comportement c'est la méthode
du compromis mais le rôle d'un président
de l'Assemblée nationale c'est de faire
en sorte que chacun vraiment trouve sa
place donc c'est vrai que les
oppositions doivent être traitées comme
la majorité ne doit pas y avoir de
préférence chaque député a la même
valeur et c'est le rôle d'un président
de l'Assemblée nationale de s'assurer
que les droits d'opposition sont
respectés je suis heureuse de voir que
les oppositions
le reconnaissent vous êtes présidente de
l'Assemblée on sent à quel point cette
question de l'impartialité vous l'avez
chez chevillée au corps c'est très en
même temps il faut bien construire des
compromis pour faire passer des réformes
sinon la dissolution sera inéluctable et
peut-être que vous ne serez plus là
voilà donc comment on fait est-ce que
vous reprenez la formule d'Elisabeth
borne sur l'arc républicain c'est-à-dire
compromis avec tous les groupes sauf le
rassemblement national et la France
insoumise moi je travaille avec tout le
monde et les compromis et les votes sont
ceux de tous les députés de la nation ce
sont tous les députés qui ont été élus
que le gouvernement souhaite travailler
de façon approfondie avec telle ou tel
groupe avec tel ou tel parti politique
c'est tout à fait normal et je et la
première ministre a tout à fait raison
de d'estimer qu'elle ne peut travailler
qu'avec telle ou tel tout ce qu'on peut
proposer l'ORL
n'est pas forcément écarté des votes de
la majorité vous en faites partie malgré
tout alors c'est vrai que vous êtes
président de l'institution on va parler
d'ailleurs de ce que vous avez comme
projet pour cette institution mais vous
vous êtes aussi membre de cette majorité
présidentielle je ne fais pas le tri
entre les votes et on voit bien depuis
le début comme je ne fais pas le tri
entre les députés les Français ont élu
577 députés et chacun est député de la
nation et donc il faut discuter avec
chacun et bâtir des compromis c'est
nécessairement
un compromis Grégoire de Fournas
d'ailleurs revient demain je dis pas de
bêtises ce député qui a eu ces mots jugé
racistes et sanctionnés lourdement ce
n'est pas un problème vous ne craignez
pas d'autres incidents avec ce retour
écoutez moi je suis très vigilante j'ai
eu l'occasion de l'exprimer à plusieurs
reprises je ne tolérerai pas des propos
qui puissent être des propos qu'ils
soient injurieux racistes ou qui prône
la haine de l'autre et je ne tolérerai
pas dans l'hémicycle mais pas plus
qu'hier qu'aujourd'hui et demain alors
on va parler à présent de vos projets
pour l'Assemblée nationale on a pu
filmer une permanence parlementaire et
elle brune Pivet d'un genre assez
nouveau vous allez le voir Stéphanie
Despierre a pu assister en partie à vos
échanges avec des Français ça s'est
passé au Palais Bourbon regardez c'est
une chose qui passe assez mal c'est le
49-3
Thomas ingénieur informatique a
rendez-vous avec la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale il est l'un des
cinq premiers à participer aux
permanence citoyenne créé par Yaël Brown
Pivet
ça vous plaît comme initiative Thomas a
été tiré au sort parmi les seins sont
français qui se sont inscrits via
Internet pour obtenir ce rendez-vous lui
s'inquiète des multiples 49-3 je suis
interrogé sur comment comment on fait on
peut sortir de ça parce qu'aujourd'hui
dans un cadre privé on nous
interrogerait sur comment vous dépensez
tout cet argent du des députés du temps
des députés sur le débat en fait qui à
la fin ne sert pas à rien mais quasiment
en fait en tête-à-tête avec la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale et
sans caméra l'entretien dure une
vingtaine de minutes mais dis-lui est
venu parler démocratie participative
c'était assez spontané mais c'est ce qui
m'a plu on aurait pu attendre peut-être
à ce que ce soit un petit peu l'angle de
bois ou non en fait ça a été assez
direct et franc Valérie elle a fait le
voyage depuis Saint-Malo car elle est
choquée par le comportement des députés
dans l'hémicycle ce qui me heurte c'est
justement tous ces
débordement râler dans mon coin ça ne
sert à rien pour moi donc je voulais
aller le dire à la présidente tout
simplement il y a LeBron Pivet tiendra
désormais c'est permanence citoyenne à
l'Assemblée une fois par mois voilà
ouvrir les murs de l'institution mais
déjà revenons quand même sur ce 49-3 sur
les quelques Français que vous avez reçu
on sent bien que ça reste très difficile
pour eux à accepter pas pour tout le
monde c'est un outil constitutionnel
mais quand même septième 49-3 tout de
même ce que je leur ai expliqué c'est
que le 49-3 a été utilisé uniquement sur
les textes budgétaires qu'ils soient que
ce soit le budget de l'État ou le budget
de la Sécurité sociale pour rien avoir
d'autre vous le savez bien oui mais pour
le moment il n'y en a pas eu d'autres et
que tous les autres textes et il y en a
eu d'ores et déjà neuf qui sont adoptés
définitivement ont été adoptés après un
vote de l'Assemblée nationale et un
accord avec le Sénat et donc c'est
toujours cet effet un peu de loupe sur
les incidents loupe sur le 49-3 sa
masque malheureusement tout le reste et
le reste c'est ce sont des textes qui
ont été votés qui ont été adoptés sur le
pouvoir d'achat sur les mesures de
soutien chèque énergie sur le texte
sanitaire sur des juges consulaires sur
la Polynésie sur l'assurance chômage la
bientôt il y aura la loop mini la
commission mixte paritaire a lieu demain
matin sur la sécurité intérieure et la
politique donc en fait l'Assemblée
nationale est en capacité d'adopter des
textes et j'aimerais bien expliquer
en même temps ça ça accentue la défiance
chez certains justement c'est pour ça
qu'il faut vraiment bien expliquer cela
dire que le 49-3 et c'est normal est un
outil à disposition lorsque nous n'avez
pas de majorité et le vote de budget
n'est pas votable j'allais dire par des
oppositions le sait tous mais qu'en
revanche pour tous les autres textes
c'est la méthode de dialogue de
compromis qui prévaut et qui nous permet
jusqu'à présent de trouver des majorités
et de trouver des compromis avec le
Sénat je vous indique que nous avons
aujourd'hui j'espère que demain ce sera
encore le cas mais nous avons 100%
d'accord avec le Sénat depuis 5 mois ça
n'est pas rien et le Sénat est dans
l'opposition c'est vrai président de la
République est au gouvernement mais il
faut dialoguer il faut il faut faire de
droite je me permets de le rappeler
qu'il aurait oublié il faut accepter de
faire des concessions vous pouvez pas
alors on va on va en parler justement
donc le gouvernement je trouve et bien
rentré dans le match et accepte de faire
ses concessions qui permettent
l'adoption des textes donc vous recevez
des des Français alors c'est pas à
l'hôtel de lacets ou le précise la
Présidence de l'Assemblée est en travaux
mais c'est quand même dans les dans les
murs de l'institution vous la trouvez un
peu trop fermé sur elle-même cette
institution qu'est-ce que vous entendez
par ouverture je trouve que physiquement
elle est déjà fermée sur elle-même
quiconque passe devant l'Assemblée
nationale est incapable de dire si il y
a de la lumière à l'intérieur aussi il
n'y en a pas parce que nous avons des
murs c'est le résultat d'une histoire et
maintenant toutes les portes sont
fermées suite aux attentats de 2015 donc
c'est vrai que cette Assemblée nationale
qui est physiquement fermée les Français
la connaissent mal et je souhaite
l'ouvrir l'ouvrir en grand l'ouvrir en
grand c'est évidemment l'ouvrir à nos
concitoyens ce sont ces permanences qui
ont eu beaucoup de succès ce sont aussi
l'ouverture de visite individuelles avec
une inscription directe sur le site de
l'Assemblée nationale nous avons ouvert
30 000 créneaux jusqu'au mois d'avril
100% d'entre eux ont été d'ores et déjà
réservés donc les Français vieilles
français viennent les Français
s'intéressent à l'institution c'est
l'ouverture à l'art aux artistes au
théâtre aux musiciens aux comédiens
un petit mot parce qu'on va voir un
sujet tout à l'heure sur ces comédiens
de la Comédie Française qui vont
interpréter et jouer les grands les
grands textes parlementaires pour quoi
les inscrire dans l'histoire les faire
connaître aussi aussi et puis pour
rappeler à notre jeunesse et au-delà aux
Français que les débats qui existent
aujourd'hui sur certaines questions
telles que la laïcité par exemple sont
des débats qui ne sont pas nés d'hier
qui irriguent la vie de notre République
la vie de notre assemblée et donc c'est
intéressant de se remettre dans ces
perspectives historiques j'ai le plaisir
de d'avoir pu nouer ce partenariat avec
la Comédie Française et aussi avec le
ministre de l'éducation nationale et
donc dans l'hémicycle il y aura des
jeunes qui auront travaillé la question
de la laïcité avec leur professeur qui
vont pouvoir assister à cette
reconstitution et qui après pourront
pendant une heure débattre avec moi des
questions de laïcité et donc vous voyez
je trouve que ce que vous faites un lien
entre c'est de faire un lien entre le
passé et le présent on verra d'ailleurs
c'est le premier je pense enrichissant
pour tout le monde voilà les images des
répétitions qui ont eu lieu avec les
comédiens c'est pour c'est pour tout à
l'heure je voulais qu'on parle un peu du
de travail Elsa il y a une réunion des
différents présidents de groupe hier à
l'Assemblée nationale qui sont ils sont
exténués faute de majorité ils doivent
figer tout le temps ils n'en peuvent
plus les députés alors on le précise ils
ne veulent pas travailler moins ils
veulent travailler mieux voilà parce que
hier aux quatre colonnes tous les
députés prêts précisez bien à toutes les
caméras attention n'est pas fatigué on
se plaint pas on sait que c'est
difficile pour tout le monde bon en vrai
tout le monde est un peu épuisé mais
c'est pas la question c'est vrai que
depuis des années il y a de plus en plus
d'heures en séance pas forcément séance
de nuit mais en séance en termes globale
et c'est vrai qu'avec une majorité
relative chaque voix compte d'habitude
dans l'hémicycle on a un peu les
connaisseurs du sujet là tout le monde y
va ça veut dire qu'on peut plus mettre
en place des permanences un roulement
comme il était d'usage et donc les
députés se retrouvent assiéger du lundi
au vendredi voire même le samedi vous
avez demandé donc à chaque groupe de
faire des propositions donc certains
violent mieux articuler le temps à
l'Assemblée en circonscription pourquoi
pas deux semaines ici à l'Assemblée une
semaine en circonscription d'autres
proposent de ne pas siéger après 20h au
moins deux soirs dans la semaine il y a
la question aussi du vendredi tout ça
au-delà des questions de rythme de
fatigue d'horaire c'est vraiment une
réflexion aussi sur le sens qu'on donne
à son mandat et sur un risque et bah
c'est d'être très très présent à Paris
mais très très absent en circonscription
c'est exactement ça vous avez vraiment
bien expliqué les choses mais parce que
être député c'est être député à Paris à
l'Assemblée nationale et on sait qu'elle
a semblé ça n'est pas qu'être dans
l'hémicycle c'est aussi être en
commission c'est aussi être en audition
et c'est aussi être en dans les
ministères en train de discuter
travailler des textes donc ça c'est une
des parties de notre mission mais notre
autre partie c'est d'être en
circonscription de rencontrer des
citoyens d'aller dans des entreprises de
voir des associations d'aller dans les
écoles etc ça on voulait finalement les
députés qui veulent pas travailler enfin
qui veulent
plus siéger le vendredi ils veulent
travailler en circonscription être
auprès de nos concitoyens c'est aussi on
va jouer le jeu mais c'est aussi ce que
nous demande nos concitoyens ils ne
veulent pas de députés hors-sol et si
nous sommes 100% de notre temps à
l'Assemblée nationale nous deviendrons
des députés hors sol et ça ça peut
relayer
les gens sont aussi choqués c'est vrai
que c'est compliqué puisqu'on a
l'impression que les électeurs veulent
un peu les deux avoir beaucoup de
députés dans l'hémicycle mais aussi
pouvoir avoir accès à leur députés c'est
pour ça que je pense qu'il faut vraiment
mieux organiser notre travail ce qui
fera que quand il y aura des séquences
dans l'hémicycle nous serons beaucoup
parce que justement ces séquences seront
peut-être un peu moins nombreuses et
plus concentrées dans la semaine que le
vendredi nous serons dans nos
circonscriptions auprès de nos
concitoyens et que nous reviendrons le
lundi à l'Assemblée nourrit de tout ce
qui nous aurait dit et je pense que ça
sera profitable pour qu'on verra
d'ailleurs si le gouvernement est
d'accord pour ne plus inscrire de textes
à l'ordre du jour le vendredi ça doit
être encore tranché on passe au réformes
à venir et elles sont de taille question
politique tout de suite
[Musique]
alors on va commencer par le gros
morceau et c'est évidemment la réforme
des retraites Elsa on n'en sait plus sur
le calendrier oui la première ministre
était devant les différents groupes de
la majorité les revenus sur ses éléments
de calendrier alors on a les contours de
la réforme qui seront bien présentés
avant Noël on parle de la deuxième
semaine de décembre avec donc les
arbitrages 64 ans 65 ans le texte lui
sera présenté en Conseil des ministres
au tout début de l'année 2023 pour être
examiné au Parlement dans la foulée avec
une entrée en vigueur espérée à l'été on
parlera donc de la méthode mais déjà sur
le fond et ce que vous dites comme tout
le monde le dit au gouvernement oui il
faut travailler plus et si oui quelle
préférence recule de l'âge légal
allongement durée de cotisation ou un
mix des deux ça va nous avons été élu
sur un programme et dans ce programme il
y avait le recul de l'âge et
l'allongement de la durée donc c'est 65
ans donc Sam initial le programme
initial mais donc le programme initial
tendait à ce que les durées soient
rallongées et que l'on fasse une réforme
de la retraite comprenant les régimes
spéciaux la pénibilité les carrières
longues etc donc ça moi je suis
évidemment une fervente défenseuse de
cette réforme ce que j'avais souhaité
selon RTL quitte à descendre dans la rue
il y aura forcément une grosse bagarre
sociale et bien restons sur les 65 ans
ce serait un membre de l'exécutif au
sommet de l'État qui leur est glissé à
nos confrères moi je ne préempte pas le
dialogue social que j'ai appelé de mes
vœux le ministre olivier dussobe est
encore en train de discussions discuter
avec les sentiments que ce soit l'âge le
recul ou que ce soit l'allongement de la
durée cotisation il y a eu trois il y a
trois cycles de discussion qui ont été
ouverts par le ministre on va laisser le
ministre à atteindre et finir ces trois
cycles de discussion on va attendre que
la première ministre nous donne les
orientations qu'elle choisit avec son
gouvernement et nous franchement
prudence donc c'est pas de la prudence
c'est le aspect du dialogue social c'est
le respect de cette concertation moi ce
qui m'importe c'est quoi
fondamentalement c'est que nous
puissions faire une réforme de la
retraite parce que nous avons besoin de
pérenniser notre système de faire en
sorte qu'il soit l'équilibre et qu'il
soit plus juste alors question ces
objectifs sont atteints pour moi ce sera
une bonne méthode nous aurons réussi
Stéphane lakowski tout à l'heure
rappelait très clairement et vous étiez
déjà présidente de l'Assemblée nationale
quand vous avez dit tout simplement que
vous n'y étiez pas pour un amendement
dans le cadre du budget de la Sécurité
sociale pour allonger l'âge légal là il
se murmure que les Français pourraient
via leur représentant à l'Assemblée
assister à une sorte de texte dédié dans
un texte budgétaire ce qui permettrait
le 49-3 est-ce que vous pensez que faire
passer cette réforme aussi important
pour les Français sans débat à
l'Assemblée via le 49-3 ce serait
accepté de nos concitoyens le 49-3 Nanny
il parle débat parlementaire vous prenez
le texte budgétaire la première partie
du projet de loi de finances il a été
débattu pendant 10 jours et le 49 3
était déclenché au bout de ses dix jours
donc et il y avait eu évidemment
l'examen en commission comment ce que je
crois c'est que le texte il est
important qu'il soit débattu au
Parlement et en commission et dans
l'hémicycle moi ce que j'espère surtout
c'est donc le scénario d'un budget
social rectificatif dédié à la partie
financière de la retraite vous n'êtes
pas contre vous y êtes plutôt favorable
moi je suis favorable à ce que ce texte
puisse être venir au Parlement et être
discuter maintenant je contre je suis
pour que ce soit un texte c'est
forcément avec un amendement
rectificatif permettra tous les 49 3
possibles mais si c'est un texte
ordinaire il permettra également un 49,3
donc pour moi ça ne change pas grand
chose plus coûte peut-être mais ça en
revanche ce que je souhaite c'est que
nous puissions débattre de ce texte pour
un débattre il ne faudrait pas que telle
ou tel groupe estime que il faudrait
déposer des tombeaux d'amendements et
des milliers d'amendements parce que moi
ce que je voulais en disant je ne
souhaite pas que ça vient pas
apparemment c'est que dans l'hémicycle
nous puissions parler pénibilités que
nous puissions parler carrière longue
que nous puissions parler emploi des
seniors que nous puissions parler recul
de là soit dans un texte budgétaire ce
qui serait dommage c'est que en déposant
beaucoup beaucoup d'amendements en fait
trois ans ils sont 75 mais dans ce cas
là nous ne pourrons pas débattre de ces
sujets qui sont fondamentaux pour les
Français et moi je veux qu'on puisse en
débattre alors je voudrais qu'on dise un
mot sur l'immigration souviens c'est un
thème sensible qui fracturait la
majorité du précédent quinquennat Elsa
là encore on en sait un peu plus oui
mardi prochain le 6 sera un débat sans
vote ici à l'Assemblée la semaine
d'après au Sénat alors le gouvernement
il continue encore ces consultations
notamment pour savoir à qui va pouvoir
bâtir des compromis le projet devrait
être présenté en début d'année et ce
qu'on sait c'est qu'il serait étudié au
Sénat avant l'assemblée Sénat de droite
tout à fait alors donc ce qui peut être
potentiellement durci par les sénateurs
et arriver ici à l'Assemblée encore plus
à droite qu'il ne l'est actuellement oui
et non après vous savez moi souvent on
me dit est-ce que ça c'est bien de
commencer par le Sénat moi ça ne me pose
aucune difficulté je suis une fervente
partisane du Bic amérisme et j'ai
toujours considéré que le travail des
sénateurs était un travail de grande
qualité aussi une dimension stratégique
a commencé sur l'immigration avec le
Sénat sur le territoire il y a un
certain nombre de mesures qui sont
issus de quelqu'un que je connais bien
qui est l'ancien l'actuel président de
la commission des Lois du Sénat François
Noel buffet avec lequel j'ai beaucoup
travaillé et qui est quelqu'un qui fait
des propositions toujours très
constructives et donc moi je n'y vois
aucun inconvénient au contraire je
trouve que le regard des sénateurs sur
ce sujet là est un regard qui est
pertinent qui est toujours intéressant
Gérald Darmanin qui est rétablir ce
qu'on appelle la double peine
c'est-à-dire l'expulsion des étrangers
condamnés ça vous y êtes favorable ou
plutôt réservé
il faudra regarder dans quelles
conditions moi je suis par principe
défavorable à toute mesure qui serait
systématique et automatique chaque
situation doit être regardée et donc il
faudra regarder les rédactions qui
seront retenues si il fallait
s'aventurer dans cette direction mais je
trouve que on ne peut pas tolérer sur le
territoire français pour être très clair
des personnes qui commettent des actes
de délinquance grave pour autant je
pense que il y a des situations qu'il
faut regarder des situations humaines et
donc il ne faut il faut se garder de
toute automatisme dans tout j'avais
gardé voilà une certaine manière de
marquer votre différence aussi on
l'entend entre les lignes je voudrais
quand même vous entendre sur l'actualité
politique et ce recours au cabinet de
conseils et notamment au cabinet
McKinsey le parquet national financier
ouvert deux informations judiciaires
l'une pour de financement illégal des
campagnes d'Emmanuel Macron 2007 2022
l'autre pour des soupçons de favorisés
on augmente pas une procédure judiciaire
vous allez me le dire simplement Bruno
Le Maire lui il a très clairement dit
que sur le recours au cabinet extérieur
de conseil il y avait eu des abus est-ce
que vous êtes d'accord avec lui en tout
cas ce qui est certain c'est
qu'effectivement il y a eu un recours
très important des conditions qui
peuvent poser question donc moi j'ai lu
attentivement le rapport de commission
d'enquête du Sénat nouveau sur ce sujet
il y avait un certain nombre de
propositions qui étaient intéressantes
donc tout cela maintenant et dans les
dans les mains de la justice donc on va
la laisser travailler mais en tout cas
effectivement ce sont des questions en
tout cas qui sont importantes vous savez
les compétences de l'État qu'elles n'ont
plus ce sont les compétences et puis ce
sont c'est l'argent des Français donc
nous devons faire attention merci
beaucoup Elsa mon dingava comme promis
avant d'accueillir nos affranchis qui
vont dialoguer avec vous et prendre un
peu de hauteur sur la crise démocratique
mais aussi sur la question des femmes
comme promis ces images la loi de 1905
sur la séparation des Églises et de
l'État comme si vous y étiez c'est votre
projet madame la Présidente Jean Jaurès
Aristide Briand interprété par des
pensionnaires de la Comédie Française
Marco pomdi a pu assister hier aux
répétitions dans l'émission le reportage
voulez-vous détruire le catholicisme ce
pays voulez-vous anéantir la religion la
France n'est pas sismatique elle est
révolutionnaire la Comédie Française en
pleine répétition mercredi prochain 5
acteurs interpréteront les grands
orateurs du débat sur la séparation de
l'Église et de l'État en 1905
Jean Jaurès il y a El Brown privé
l'actuel présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale a accepté de jouer son propre
rôle merci beaucoup
[Musique]
voilà c'est magnifique je pense qu'on va
on va faire quelque chose de bien c'est
dans ce même hémicycle il y a 117 ans
que l'assemblée votait le compromis de
1905 à l'époque pas de micro ni de
caméra la reconstitution des débats
s'est faite à partir des comptes-rendus
des 48 séances Bruno Fellini le monsieur
de l’assemblée a étudié plus de 2000
pages de journal officiel le but était
évidemment délégué mais sans trahir et
donc j'ai commencé par lire ces débats
c'était le plus long évidemment et
ensuite par les condensés pour rester
vraiment sur ce qui est intemporel ce
qui a du sens aujourd'hui encore 117 ans
après un dialogue entre le passé et le
présent car cette loi de 1905 est un
héritage 300 lycéens assisteront à cette
unique représentation il siègeront aux
côtés des acteurs dans l'hémicycle un
moyen de transmettre aux jeunes
générations le pourquoi du comment de
cette laïcité à la française un débat
toujours d'actualité la loi de 1905 a
elle est toujours un petit peu en débat
donc effectivement c'est maintenir une
question importante sur le feu c'est
surtout revenir à ceux qui l'ont écrit
ceux qui l'ont pensé faire remonter du
passé les origines de la loi les
origines de la loi à savoir par la
neutralité de l'État en matière de
religion la liberté de conscience
liberté de croire et celle de ne pas
croire je voterai donc contre au nom de
la France catholique et de la liberté
les hommes ne sont parfois que trop
portés à ni et tout progrès qui ne
s'affirme pas par une violence de
brillant voilà alors il y a le brune
pylen petite réaction vous avez des
dates à nous communiquer début décembre
une plaque Aristide Briand voilà tout à
fait donc le mardi 6 décembre la
position de la plaque d'Aristide Briand
donc rapporteur de la loi de 1905 et
prix Nobel de la Paix seul parlementaire
qui a eu ce prix et le lendemain le 7
décembre au matin à un moment où
l'hémicycle n'est pas occupé par les
députés puisqu'ils sont en commission
nous aurons cette reconstitution des
débats avec la Comédie Française et sera
présent bien évidemment pour les jeunes
et les moins jeunes bonsoir Pierre-Henri
tavoyau et merci de nous avoir rejoints
bonsoir on avait envie voilà en fin de
cette émission spéciale d'organiser un
dialogue avec d'abord le philosophe que
vous êtes Pierre-Henry puisque vous
présidez le collège de philosophie sur
votre sujet de prédilection la
démocratie plus jamais en crise oui une
question sur la démocratie
représentative parce que on peut avoir
quelques doutes d'un côté elle est un
peu contestée parce qu'on appelle la
démocratie participative et puis vous
n'êtes pas aidé par votre président
parce que il y a le Conseil national de
la refondation il y a la convention
citoyenne pour le pour le d'abord pour
le climat puis ensuite pour la fin de
vie voilà votre évaluation mais je dois
dire aussi cette démocratie
représentative est un peu aussi
fragilisée par par la tentation de
constante aujourd'hui de vouloir tout
constitutionnaliser alors il y a eu le
vote essence sur la
constitutionnalisation de l'IVG il y en
a d'autres c'est-à-dire l'idée qu'au
fond c'est un message envoyé aux
Français écoutez voilà le travail
parlementaire c'est pas très sérieux
pour que ça soit vraiment sérieux et
solide voilà feu figer ça dans la
Constitution donc entre l'empire du
droit
en disant c'est eux qui vont faire la
politique et puis cette idée de
démocratie participative aujourd'hui
c'est quoi la démocratie représentative
je pense
que moi je vais pas partir de ceux qui
opposent la démocratie représentative à
la démocratie participative et je suis
convaincu que nos concitoyens ont envie
de s'intéresser s'intéressent à la vie
de la passion et on vit justement et non
et ont envie de participer au-delà de
l'élection simplement de leur
représentants et qu'ils veulent pouvoir
s'exprimer sur des sujets de fond moi je
pense maintenant que notre enjeu à nous
c'est vraiment de bien articuler les
deux et de bien montrer la
complémentarité il ne faut pas que les
citoyens se fient des politiques et il
ne faut pas que les politiques se
méfient des citoyens pas le sentiment
d'une concurrence parfois multiplier les
conseils nationaux
je suis d'accord avec vous mais ça
serait le Parlement qui serait le
gestionnaire de ces instances
participatives parce que si c'est pas le
Parlement c'est inévitablement soit
l'exécutif et là il y a des situations
de concurrence parce que le choix que
nous avons fait n'est pas celui-là et je
pense que si nous avions confié la
gestion de la démocratie participative
au Parlement nous aurions entraîné une
confusion des rôles et probablement dans
l'esprit de nos concitoyens
toute la loi a été faite avec des
comités délibératifs avec des
conférences de consensus ça c'est fait
tout à fait mais nous le choix que nous
avons fait pendant le précédent le
quinquennat c'est de considérer que le
Conseil économique social et
environnemental devait être cette
chambre de la participation citoyenne et
nous lui avons confié à travers une loi
organique la capacité à organiser les
conventions citoyennes ce qu'il va faire
prochainement pour une convention sur la
fin de vie et vous voyez moi je crois
tellement à la complémentarité des deux
exercices que je vais aller m'exprimer
au CES œufs devant la convention
citoyenne sur la fin de vie pour
justement expliquer cela et leur dire
que c'est nos exercices sont
complémentaires et c'est important dans
les deux sens parce que vous aviez vu
que pendant la convention climat il y
avait plus avoir un malentendu et de se
dire que en fait mais de la part des
conventionnés pensant que ils étaient
décisionnaires et que le Parlement
paroles présidentielle qui a dit que les
propositions seraient reprises sans
filtre aussi a pu jouer
c'est-à-dire que les c'est un peu ça que
je vais aller expliquer pour la
Convention sur la fin de vie de dire que
nous allons être très respectueux de
leur travail et qu'il va nous intéresser
au plus haut point il s'est fondamental
surtout sur des sujets comme ça que les
citoyens s'en emparent mais que dans un
deuxième temps le Parlement lorsqu'il
sera saisi d'un projet de loi va rentrer
dans son travail de délibération et va
évidemment modifier le texte mais j'ai
envie de vous dire c'est le lot du
gouvernement depuis des décennies
lorsqu'il présente un projet de loi ce
n'est pas le projet de loi qui est voté
après à l'Assemblée nationale
sur la constitutionnalisation
profondément que notre Constitution est
là elle doit accepter toute la politique
nos droits et libertés fondamentaux
organisé le pouvoir public et bien je
considère que le droit à l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse fait partie des
droits fondamentaux de la femme qui
doivent être protégées
c'est justement que la volonté générale
décide solennellement que effectivement
ce droit existe qu'est-ce que la
constitutionnalisation apporte de plus
justement aux États-Unis c'est la Cour
suprême qui dit j'hésite voilà on va
changer les choses parce que justement
il y a pas cette volonté générale qui
s'est exprimée en France il y a pas
d'ambiguïté il y a pas d'ambiguïté mais
il ne faut pas avoir un raisonnement
purement juridique sur ces sujets là moi
vous savez justement
j'ai rencontré en Pologne des femmes qui
se battent pour simplement le droit à la
contraception pour se battre pour le
droit à l'avortement c'est pas le fond
je termine ma phrase et ces femmes je
leur ai posé la question
qu'est-ce que je peux faire moi en tant
que président de l'Assemblée nationale à
part vous soutenir soutenir votre combat
parce qu'elles m'ont dit c'est nous
avons besoin que la France porte le
flambeau des droits et de l'universalité
c'est droit et bien fait une loi qui est
extraordinaire qui est jamais absolument
pas contesté mais elle n'est pas
contestée et c'est heureux elle pourra
l'être demain mais ce serait une réforme
constitutionnelle peut être aussi changé
et une majorité avec le dernier mot
c'est pas la même chose c'est 3/5 des
deux chambres c'est 3/5 des deux
chambres une loi ordinaire
et cette loi que j'allais dire
l'obstacle de la Constitution sera pas
c'est pas un argument décisif le fait
que aujourd'hui en 2022 en tant que
président de l'Assemblée nationale je
mène ce combat pour cette
constitutionnalisation et je porte ou
non de toutes les femmes du monde
oui mais c'est pas c'est pas le problème
politique
c'est une évidence avant de passer la
parole il y a tout à fait un lien
d'ailleurs sur la sanctuarisation dans
la constitution de l'IVG les achats une
petite question Emmanuel Macron
aime-t-il le Parlement je me pose la
question parce que à force de faire des
conseils nationaux de la résistance le
mot est très très fort le fondation de
la refondation pardonnez-moi mais je
pense au CNR on se pose la question de
savoir si véritablement il est il est
dans ce à la fois cette séparation des
pouvoirs et puis cette nouvelle donne
politique qu'on souhaitait les Français
vous savez le CNR associe étroitement le
Parlement que ce soit au niveau national
ou au niveau local et les parlementaires
participent activement à toutes ces
déclinaisons donc moi je ne suis pas
encore une fois la confiance elle doit
être réciproque et aujourd'hui elle
l'est elle fait dit les haches en
Boncelles vous voulez revenir sur la
grande cause du quinquennat et parfois
ce décalage entre la société civile qui
avance vite sur ce sujet là qui a des
attentes importantes et puis la loi et
la classe politique surtout en effet
bonsoir madame la Présidente merci de me
donner cette occasion de vous poser
cette question qui est que pouvez-vous
faire en tant que président de
l'Assemblée nationale pour faire en
sorte que les promesses qui ont été
prises par le Président de la République
et votre majorité souhaitent
effectivement mis en oeuvre je
m'explique nous sommes aujourd'hui
lequel je somme nous le 30 novembre 2022
et depuis le 1er janvier il y a déjà eu
124 féminicides depuis le début du
premier quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron en
2017 les féminicides n'ont pas reculé
les les agressions sexuelles n'ont pas
reculé les moyens des associations ont
certes légèrement augmenté néanmoins le
budget du ministère de l'Égalité pour
les femmes et l'égalité famome pardon
reste l'un des plus petits budgets de
l'État que faire effectivement entre ces
annonces qui semblent relever d'une
certaine forme de communication
politique qui sont parfois et c'est le
sentiment des associations sur le
terrain qui ont le sentiment que c'est
saupoudré de petites mesures mais qu'il
n'y a pas de véritable réforme
structurelle pour lutter le milliard le
fameux milliard que réclame les
associations qui est passé à 2 milliards
désormais qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qu'on
peut attendre réellement de ce
quinquennat dans la matière je partage
pas du tout votre analyse nous avons ce
n'est pas mon analyse c'est l'analyse
des associations sur le terrain alors
c'est vraiment constate un gros décalage
entre les annonces les moyens je me
partage pas et moi qui vais beaucoup sur
le terrain là je reviens de Lille où
j'ai passé une journée avec la députée
violette spielbou justement consacré à
la lutte des violences faites aux femmes
et j'ai échangé longuement avec
plusieurs associations et plusieurs
femmes victimes de violence et ce n'est
pas ce qu'elles m'ont dit donc peut-être
que certaines associations pensent que
vous dites mais ça n'est pas la totalité
de ces associations
et bien les chiffres parlent d'eux-mêmes
nous avons voté quatre textes pendant la
précédente mandature plus un texte sur
l'égalité des des hommes et des femmes
dans le monde
aussi
la libération de la parole vous avez
raison il y a la libération de la parole
mais nous avons fait du gouver nous
avons fait mais nous avons
formé des policiers pour recueillir
cette parole pour recueillir cette
parole c'est très important nous avons
signé des conventions avec les hôpitaux
pour pouvoir justement lorsque les
femmes se rendent dans des hôpitaux que
la le dépôt de plainte que la
recueille des des éléments permettant de
matérialiser l'infraction soit facilité
nous avons accéléré profondément la
prise en charge judiciaire avec la
réduction considérable des délais de
l'ordonnance de protection qui avant
mettait à peu près 40 jours avant d'être
prononcé qui maintenant doit être
prononcé dans un délai maximum de six
jours nous avons doté toutes les
juridictions de bracelets anti
rapprochement de téléphone grave danger
très
importants disent qu'effectivement les
ce qu'on appelle les TGD et les bas ont
effectivement été augmentés mais les
moyens pour accompagner les personnes
bénéficiaires n'ont pas été augmentées
donc aujourd'hui les associations se
retrouvent à devoir gérer ces fameux
dispositifs sont les moyens nécessaires
c'est quand même mais vous voyez que là
nous en sommes d'accord nous avons fait
des choses nous n'avons pas rien et bien
sûr et ce qui serait pas temps de passer
une étape supérieure moi je crois que
l'exemple espagnol par exemple
spécial formé avec des juges dédiés et
moi ces questions des violences
dédiés et formés à ces questions partout
sur le territoire et moi je considère
que avoir des réussi peut-être là où on
a encore du mal mais non quasiment
éradiquer on a fait des progrès mais
majeurs il y a encore beaucoup à faire
et c'est un combat qui doit tous nous
occuper évidemment le gouvernement le
Parlement les associations qui font un
boulot extraordinaire en la matière mais
parce que il y a cette limiter cette
humanité c'est bien moi j'ai fait partie
du monde associatif je sais ce qu'elles
apportent sur ces causes là sur ces
combats là mais c'est un combat qui doit
tous nous préoccuper bien évidemment les
élus locaux moi j'ai visité une un
bâtiment qui allait bientôt dans
quelques mois accueillir plus de 45
femmes victimes de violence donc et
c'est une volonté du maire de la
préfecture de l'État qui financement
tous les acteurs sont mobilisés et le
fait de faire une grande cause du
quinquennat permet c'est la validation
et va plus vite que la loi pour terminer
madame la présidentielle bonne Pivet
peut-être cette question se pose aussi à
l'Assemblée nationale on a parlé du me
too en politique est-ce qu'il faut créer
davantage de dispositifs les
collaborateurs les députés il y a eu
évidemment des des cas des cas
d'ouverture d'information judiciaire et
même des condamnations parmi la
représentation nationale il faut faire
davantage ce qui est important c'est que
avec me tool la parole c'est libérée il
faut une fois que cette parole est
libérée que l'on puisse la recueillir
l'écouter partout et donc elle a semblé
nationale nous avons cette cellule
anti-harcèlement qui existe qui
recueille les témoignages et qui peut
effectivement faire des articles 40 pour
porter plainte c'est fondamental il faut
continuer et il faut toujours encourager
les femmes les victimes à parler merci
beaucoup merci infiniment il y a LeBron
d'être venu en direct une heure de
direct sur la chaîne parlementaire ça
sera pour une présidente de l'Assemblée
vous avez un modèle parmi vos
prédécesseurs d'ailleurs pour terminer
d'un mot un grand président qui vous
inspire une présidente Philippe Seguin
Philippe Seguin et ben voilà c'est dit
parce que je crois qu'il portait
vraiment comme tous les autres mais
peut-être lui a incarné très fort
l'amour de l'institution merci beaucoup
merci à vous de Pierre Henri tavoyau Léa
chambres celle qu'on retrouve dans cette
émission très des soirées sur SCPI à
demain
[Musique]